if you were hoping to play South Park
the fractured but whole anytime soon
then you may be out of luck the follow
up to the stick of truth has been
delayed again and this time the release
window is even less specific
I'm Matt this is a GameSpot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more fart exploding coverage of South
Park video games South Park the
fractured but whole was set to arrive
sometime by the end of March but has now
been delayed sometime between April 2017
and March 2018
Ubisoft didn't provide an explanation
for South Park's rescheduling but the
original delay from December 2016 was
done to make sure the game experience
meets the high expectations of fans the
stick of truth was praised in game spots
review for nailing the South Park humour
and aesthetic the reviewer Kevin Van Ord
was disappointed by how easy short and
shallow it was the fractured but whole
may be a sequel to the stick of truth
but it's traded the Paper Mario like RPG
combat for something more akin to
turn-based strategy we'll keep you
up-to-date on all your fractured but
whole news but if you want to know more
about South Park and other TV shows make
sure to head over to our GameSpot
Universe YouTube channel
you